for a decade Washington DC has been a
celebrated national model of school
reform then in January and audit showed
that one-third of DC's high school
graduates should not have received
diplomas indeed it turns out that the
system's true graduation rate is lower
than it was in 2011 how could this have
gone unnoticed blogger Alexander
Rousseau is placed part of the blame on
rank boosterism by the capital's
preeminent news outlet but this coverage
reflects a larger problem the bandwagon
mentality and school reform since 2007
philanthropists have poured more than a
hundred and twenty million dollars into
DC schools and advocates and think tanks
were lauded for glowing accounts of
developments in DC it was easy for
reformers to feel they'd be labeled
unhelpful or anti reform for going
off-script this all fueled or with us or
against us mindset then which no one
looked too hard for problems DC's should
be a wake-up call for a school reform
culture that has been heavy on
cheerleading and light on skepticism
what do you make of the Washington DC
graduation rate scandal let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI